[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round three of the
summer classic here in st. Louis but
seif Dhirubhai Lee and vara Cobian
continued their undefeated campaigns in
the top section at three wins apiece
the pair is yet to face off not far
behind is Sam Savion who won a passed
pawn race against Dutch Benjamin Bach
Group B action included Kazakhstan's
dinara Santo a cassava making her first
trip to the US count with a win over a
bohemian Alejandra Ramirez wasn't
impressed with his own play but his
imperfection was enough against Bellis
who can't get off the ground in this
event round four coverage starts now
twenty international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as us chess champs
calm presents the first ever summer
chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Louis
chess club studio and the fourth round
of 2018 summer chess classic I am women
grandmaster Katharina Nemcova and I'm
here with international master Eric
Rosen now let's see yesterday's results
of Round three before we look at the
games of the round of today that's right
we had a very exciting day yesterday
with three decisive games sam-7
Nassif Tara Bailey and bruising dacovian
all defeating their opponents if we take
a look at the standings both Asif's Tara
Bailey Andrews and a Cobian perfect so
far three out of three and what happened
yesterday in Group B let's get the
graphics and see that protect Abraham
Ian unfortunately lost to Daenerys adieu
a cassava Josh freed el drew against
Camille Dragoon Robert Iger sorry Andrew
against Sergey Matenga
vladimir bellows lost again
unfortunately against Alejandro Ramirez
and JJ Alomar and a draw against Andre
stop walking and if we take a look at
the Group B standings we can see there's
one clear leader Camille dragon two and
a half out of three and unfortunately
for Vladimir Bellas he was zero the
three going into this round he actually
just lost his game so here's our other
four very very tough start for Vladimir
and a format of the tournament we have
two ten player round-robin groups with a
time control of 90 minutes for 40 moves
plus 30 minutes for the remainder of the
game
additionally we have 30 second
increments throughout the game and let's
note that players are no they are not
allowed to agree on a draw before move
30 if we take a look at the schedule for
the event we have games starting every
day at 1:00 p.m. st. Louis time until
the last day where the game starts at 11
a.m. Central time and if there's a tie
in any group there will be a playoff at
5:00 p.m. on Wednesday the 23rd and
today's pairing for group a round four
we have Benjamin Bach against Purusha
Kobe on vasudevaya Lee against Rina Juma
buyeth Peter Prohaska against Jeffrey
shank and we have to already results for
arrows Arabic who drew against Alex
indeed and Sam Savion who drew against
Daniel Friedman and the key matchup for
Group A is Benjamin balk against erosion
a Cobian version actually breaking into
the top hundred in the world on live
rating ratings list with the win
yesterday I'm sure he's looking for
blood in this game and if we take a look
at the current position there's been
some some very interesting developments
after a somewhat peaceful petra
variation version has lunged forward
with this move c4 as been feingold would
say this move is very explosive and
version looks to be trying to open up
more lines on the queenside and create
some some immediate attack against the
king and we will definitely sustain with
this game and look more but let's see
what are the group pairings for Group B
that's right we have some very exciting
matchups for group B Daenerys I do a
cassava against andrey zhuk open we
actually have 3 games that are done
Alejandro Ramirez drawing 8jj a lemur on
D in what was a very boring exchange
French no need to look at that game
we have Sergei Motte Senko recently
defeating Vladimir Bellis camille dragon
against robert august Arion that game
still pending and tot of abraham ian and
playing her former coach Josh Vidal and
what was a very quick draw and the game
of the day is bought for Camille Dragoon
against Robert a Kesari on Camille is
the leader of Group B with two and a
half points and Robert is the Armenian
very solid Grandmaster with one and a
half points let's see what is happening
in the game that's right and when we
were looking earlier it was a very
strategic Queens gambit declined
position but there's been some recent
moves it looks like White has gone for a
very interesting efore pawn break trying
to trying to open up more lions and
perhaps target some of the weaknesses in
blacks position detaii 4 was played when
I take e4 Knight DB 695 and f6 brings us
to the current position not sure what to
make of this position it seems like
there might be some trades between the
Knights on c4 and E 5 and
I don't know it seems like still going
to be a positional and perhaps tactical
battle yes it looks like both players
will be fighting for for a win here so
let's live review the prizes what the
players are actually fighting for that's
right we have a very generous prize fund
for group a 22,000 dollars up for grabs
with a $6,000 first-place prize lots of
money on the line yes and the group B
also has a very generous prize fund with
the top prize 4000 and a total price of
$14,000 that's right and I'm sure the
players will be taking every game very
seriously
every half point counts as there's a
very big differential between 1st and
2nd place so it's gonna come down to
some of these later rounds so what if
you go back to the VARs game against
Benjamin Bach because I thought it was
very interesting position that's right
we should we should take a look at the
scheme because Benjamin Bach has been
thinking for a while after after a VAR
lunge forward with c4 and if we just
take a look at the time as far is has
it's just a great time advantage 35
minutes just under nine minutes for
Benjamin Bach and there there's still 20
moves away from time control yes I'm
thinking if taking bishop on e6
connecting the pawns maybe that's not
the move that whitey wants to do but
White has to decide maybe rook H e1 just
to develop yeah rook he1 not a bad idea
put the rook on the same file as Box
King I'm wondering if I mean black seems
ready to capture on b3 and it seems like
the Queen side is gonna be able so we
have to decide so probably what is
thinking between before or capturing so
maybe not rock 81 I was in business
envisioning some line this rook he1 C
take b3 yeah I mean Black has just so
much firepower
directed at b3 the scene was just very
bad for whites so yeah maybe I'll move
like before when you're being attacked
it's very important that you try and
enclose down as many lines as possible
but before also looks weakening I mean
it might run into a move like Queen a
for as
three could also be a weakness so let's
see what Benjamin's gonna decide to play
here and maybe let's move on to Jeffrey
Zhang and Peter Prohaska game
yeah the Jeffrey game honestly this
position makes me want to fall asleep
very symmetrical pawn structure there
are bishops of the same color so maybe
some play for whites given that the
pawns on the Queen side and also this f7
pawn are all on light squares but
honestly I'm not sure if if this game is
going to go much longer it looks like
both players doing very fine on time and
I mean I don't think there's enough
imbalances for either side to play for
much more and we actually have one of
the players ready to to come and join us
in the studio so before we come before
he comes in let's see what's happening
on board vasudevaya and Rena Juma buyeth
they're also very interesting opening
where Vasa decided to sacrifice a pawn
right and we should actually go back and
take a look at the seats opening
preparation because I was actually very
impressed he he repeated a line that
he's played before it's advanced
variation of the French defense and he's
actually had this exact position before
after Queen take b2 and previously he
played 92 which is a mainline but in
this game he played the move Knight c3
which is actually a very rare move I
don't think there's been too many games
after Knight c3 and the idea is to
sacrifice a pawn after Queen takes c3
Bishop d2 Queen a3 Black is up a pawn
but White has a much nicer development
good center and nice pace advantage so
if we go forward to see how the game per
crest it took a long time for black to
actually develop the pieces and I really
like the way the Seif continued to make
progress in this position he played the
somewhat paralyzing move rook b6 where
the rook is actually very stable on b6
after Queen c7 rook F b1 it seems like
white is just dominating all areas of
boredom and black is still yet to
develop most of the pieces after bishop
seven actually really like of Asif's
next move Bishop d1 very subtle idea
that he simply wants to play queen d3
and bishops he to and get a possible
checkmating battery against the black
Queens against the black King side yeah
I'm very surprised that Renaud chose
this variation against bossy who is very
active very stubborn player instead of
choosing something that's more solid
that's right and we should zoom for
until or until the current position
because many more moves have been played
to see if continued to to improve his
pieces and if we continue continue going
forward we can see the time situation of
a thief with over fifty minutes left
Jumma by of severely low on time many
more moves have been played let's just
zoom forward here Bishop g7 leads us to
the current position
seems like massif is taking his time and
Renata mabye off' can't be happy with
what's unfolding and what about the game
Daenerys at Arak isola against Ibaka
Andre let's get to that game we have a
cross Catalan there if we take it from
beginning so there was d4
Knight of 6 so we had an opening here
kadala and everything looks like it's
very peaceful
Bishop a4 developing rugby one night h5
rooks you on c5 here black didn't even
try to go and go for any repetition with
maybe Knight f6 Bishop f4 9 h5 but it's
also saying with this that he is playing
for when he's not trying to to go for
any repeated moves so b5 happened 95
this is one of the key squares where you
do want to control the Efus and have the
bishop on g2 open for the diagonal
Bishop e7 c5 after we should be 7 white
may want to think black may want to
think about maybe taking as it can on c4
and then doing something with the bishop
and that's why why I decided to play c5
and block the pawn structure so the
bishop on b7 is actually not that good
anymore so f5 happened Knight takes D 7
and let's fast forward to the current
position
Queen c7
Bishop before Bishop d7 93 can see how
white is controlling the dark squares
shop yet Roxy 194 395 Bishop h5 rook e1
and finally white succeeded to play if
or to go for some crash in the center
and to fight for the pieces to have some
better squares and after it takes before
de niro is now thinking what to do she
has 23 minutes well she probably will
just recapture so let's see what
happened we will go back to this game
but we I have a player of the tournament
be here sir game at Cinco Sergei welcome
this is this your first time in st.
Louis or second time second time what
did you play here for the first time I
will play incorporate some international
chess do you enjoy doing perfect
congratulations for your when you had
three draws today I win what can you
tell us about your game here it's hard
to talk about my game what do you like
when my team is playing into the no way
yeah he started with three draws now we
so now yes all I mean three losses
obvious and under loss so what happened
so actually I wasn't prepared for was
this opening because usually should play
some of the kinks engines I was so that
also surprised from your opponent yeah I
guess so I played this position against
freedom and here I played castle in
Queen c2 and in this game I decided do
not repeat you know my previous games I
played 24
- so this little theory yeah I guess I
played this position against the usually
quiet so here I guess the main lines can
be sixes I remember
and so Queen b6 e XP 5 take rook oh my G
five figures oh no no maybe not take
maybe 95% yeah
yes 95 bishops you talking [ __ ] - yeah
it should be this should be mainland cuz
like my plan is played day three we
should be 394 slowly so d3 - place yeah
so it's my plan so I don't know here
yeah now I'm trading like takes a takes
b5 so she needs to play something like
want to take here and then okay so let's
see it'll be eight like take take g3 I
guess I mean should be full position you
know I drew is and you are okay with
going through this game yeah I wasn't
prepared also I was like okay so before
what's the surprise
yeah actually I guess I played this
position if it's black against but she
wrote me three it was maybe difference
was like my night was gonna be eight in
Bishop on g6 and so after night g1 I
remember I was the game without any
chances so here after before I was quite
happy so I just played ninety one and so
my plan is super simple I wouldn't play
d3 it like b3 so what do you think about
this part I don't know she boys
I was surprised support it looks like
very weak especially the King is still
still not Castle at all like doesn't
seem to have a good cooperation with its
pieces it's hard to explain the small
fingers when you have three losses you
know maybe it seems like yeah why not
you know so what do you think is better
than c4 Bishop d6 Bishop d6
93 Castle so yeah but it's I guess in my
opinions like better for white
maybe not myself or maybe just be three
Bishop it to him why does Burke sharing
this but what is very comfortable
yeah just one maybe d4 maybe I don't
even need to play g3 so maybe I will
play d4
maybe that's what blight didn't want to
allow you to play B wants you forest
it's very risky but it's hard to play
when you have three losses on your
record
so 93 should force me to take okay is it
a sacrifice or a loss of a part actually
I hadn't known you better ask him you
know after they die just I don't think
I'll just wait
normal moves you know Clara with the
floor losses yes 95 here I played a five
so I'm just I didn't want to let him
play a five so at the end you didn't
want to put the bishop here I don't need
because he'll play 95 Bishop c3 and
maybe some put some piss on Syrian okay
so this can actually become an issue
yeah you should be too I was surprised
it'll be fine
so no this point is also weakness and we
are already poor now this may be so yeah
here I have a problem I don't need I
need some space for my pieces so I
played Bishop III because I wanted to
take on c5 and I did too so you wanted
to just take on c5 and 92-93 bring all
my pieces to the game so 95 yeah you
just took Nyjah to and here yeah I was
surprised 96 so I thought maybe he needs
to play like rook c8 Bishop c6 Bishop e5
you know do not straight bishops when
you trade bishops uncomfortable but if
I'm a rook c8
can just white go for yeah my probably
six yeah I don't like in b3 because my
night on g2 is kind of weird
yeah okay so what do you want to play
inside of conversely the other like 93
III Queenie - rg1
I mean there's clearly no compensation
yeah sure
so your pawn up maybe we will get
another one who knows but we don't have
any yeah i was i agree to play this
position of exponents if I've you know
people I said yes
okay so black played Knight f6 that's
very good move because yeah I just
traded my shot yeah I guess it's only
chance you know it's true he's trying to
somehow attack my king
I thought this a form of is really good
yes it blogs the Queen from doing
anything here it takes away the cool
actually
if I've is a threat so we the knight
would be after if I the knight is
attacked and the rook will be attacked
as well
so if I am here he wants to play like
you in c8 and knish three I guess so I
didn't know how to play it like maybe
six at least to try something right yes
here and hope for someone IG 45 so might
be 695 again I mean oh there is no Queen
h3 your something is really weak also I
guess I'm like 95 you know when I'm like
an animove I can play 95 train I mean
three nights no not after Lucas six you
know kind of okay so yeah guys 90 for
example so so tonight can I take yes but
I didn't like it I mean 95 is much
better I just want to take on your six
it makes sense I mean the night on b3 is
not doing much so we just bring it you
actually say well yeah my only like goal
in this position is a straight Queens
you know like reinforce what was its it
then we just go to end game with another
extra pollen before the rook is
strolling out of the game that looks
like a saber world she kind of play
Queen the seven because of night c8
so if Queen e7 i CIA agent so yeah you
can go back on loans just 7sp play
queens the servants 96 I mean there are
so many issues with black pieces because
they are not coordinated your own last
ranks so if you go back also you cannot
take one yeah I mean you can take that
illusion so it takes so okay like rooks
euphoric Swan so super comfortable if
you take on b6 first no no no no this
position after community for
you should take take I guess oh maybe I
will take Quinn first yeah I'll take a
green future if 98 takes some v6 you
cannot play rugby six because of knidos
oh yeah appropriate just therapy
yeah this is a very difficult position
for black it's kind of hopeless so let's
wait 94 to try for some attack maybe to
grab the pole on h2
yeah what's so you cannot see yeah so
you're gonna take night h2 because of
fructose of g5 broken one we should you
to look one it - yes for example night
h2 broke a tool like Bishop g5 okay one
Bishop - we have to be careful because
some terminals you are happening okay
that's it the bishop has to go back yes
Austin well very nice game it looked
like a very easy easy win not much work
I'm surprised as I said AHA so I have a
question what do you think about a world
championship karaoke and didn't didn't
win the candidates how how Russia feels
about that I mean I feel alright okay so
you focus on your chest
yeah sure and you are a chess
professional alright no Ivan's yeah I'm
a student of Texas Tech good luck in the
tournament congratulations for today and
hope for the best
so let's look at the game of the sieve
against
Reena Juma by f let's see if we can okay
so here are some new games you know new
moves so Roxy three happen broke h 3u o
h2 and we see that Vasi is attacking the
king here
and I see what's happening okay it's
some troubles here this night is active
but all black ones all white wants to do
is just to capture and create some some
space and some open file for the king
what do you think Eric we are joined
back by Eric Rosen internal master good
to be back I mean I have to say that
it's usually a bad sign if we just clear
the arrows here if you see most of your
pieces on the side of your opponent's
king and your opponent has most of the
pieces on the other side it's not a good
sign for black and if we look at the
time situation I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if this game ends very soon if
I see he's how many points he has he's
perfect he's leading the tournament if
he wins this game he'll go forward to a
perfect four out of four I can't do much
better than that it looks like he's
unstoppable and oh wow Luke t3 happened
rook g3 some tricks because if the pro
takes then we have neither three and a
queen so very clever move but I have a
feeling it's just a desperate attempt to
create some complications of course we
should point out the the beauty of this
where the Queen would then be aligned
with the like with the white King and
this could walk into Knight f3 so I
think the C fairy wisely instead of
playing pawn take g3 you very simply
played king h1 which brings us to the
current position looks like a move was
just played Knight f5 and I think the
strategy for black is to try and
complicate things to maybe create some
situation where we're receive could go
wrong but that's not always a great
strategy when you have less than a
minute on the talk that's what I wanted
to say he has only 30 seconds if I am if
I'm correct okay he made a move Knight
a5 so I got five very strange position
both both the knight and the the black
rook are attacked by white pawns looks
like the thief has a lot of times to
sort through the complications here yes
and I don't understand what can happen
if just I what if I just take the rook
pawn takes rook Knight takes pawn king
g2 I mean there are no pieces around
looking to attack it
that seems like black probably doesn't
have enough fuel for the attack though
maybe there could be some continuation
here 94 hitting the Queen and perhaps
threatening the somewhat scary Queen
I've to check so I go Queen a for Queen
F for defending everything and I mean
white would just be up a rook and still
have the massive attack yeah I would
expect this game to be over just a few
more moves the thief might just take a
good amount of time here just to make
sure that he's not missing anything
that's the beauty when you have 42
minutes and your opponent has less than
a minute you can just kind of calm down
take as much time as you need to sort
things out and we didn't spend much time
on the game Peter Prohaska Jefferies
wrong so let's see what what would
happen there yeah last time we left I
was falling asleep to this game I think
I'm still falling asleep if we notice
some pawns have got gotten traded white
is playing F for perhaps trading more
pawns about this game it's gonna be
probably draw soon as well right and we
should note F for it was played on mu
for T so so both players doing very fine
on time yeah I don't think there's too
much to play for with either side so
let's move on what about the leader of
Group B camel dragon against Robert a
Kesari on that's right this is our key
matchup for today and the the play seems
to be getting a lot spicier especially
after blacks last move pawn f4 putting
the question to the bishop on g3 it
looks like white might be forced to
retreat to h2 which is not the happiest
square for the bishop that's definitely
not the bishop would like to have some
open diagonals but what can you do when
somebody plays f4 that's true I mean
even if the bishop isn't so thrilled to
be on h2 that White's Knights do look
pretty nice on on e5 and c5 a very
complex position there's there's a lot
of pressure here a lot of pieces
directed at this
five this a five square block attacking
the knight on e5 three times and we
should note when f4 is played it does
obstruct the bishop from from defending
the night so if i'm not mistaken after
white plays maybe the expected Bishop to
h2 can black get away with winning upon
in five I'm I just kind of drag when
he's such a strong player and he's
already thinking about this move for
four minutes when Bishop h2 looks such
as such a long to you'll move so I
wonder maybe there is another thing that
we are missing there any other candidate
moves for light is there and sometimes
when you're being attacked the the
obvious instinct is to look for defense
but sometimes you want to look for
counter-attack the only counter
attacking move that comes to mind is
something like Knight takes e4 which I
just see has been played
kamil dragon appears to be getting up
from his seats but Robert responded
right away with the move rook to e1 so
lots of traits happening because if I
didn't take on a one and just recaptured
at night maybe I can take on I ate and
then even play Bishop h4 and actually
securing a very nice diagonal for the
bishop I see what you mean so White's
idea would be after take white could
maybe find a happier Square from the
bishop but that did not happen
the Brooks did get traded on a one which
brings us to the current position where
like I said show us which piece to take
yes I guess it's a question of I mean
which piece could be more valuable for
white and then which piece should you
just take off the board any first
instincts here from from the backside I
mean usually I want to take bishops when
the position is open class we are kind
of destroying the pawn structure would
be take c4 but the night's going to be
also very active tonight can jump to e5
and with the other I don't see five
there can be some troubles but no like
decided to tell you the bishop and I
like it's this decision because it aims
to open up the Kings side I mean we
should keep in mind White's tonight is
still attacked and now there's there's
this pawn on g3 which is likely going to
trade for the f2 pawn exposing White's
king of it more and we also have to keep
in mind this
for pawn is isolated and it can be well
it's already attacked by the bishop it
can be pressured again by the Queen and
it seems like black might have some some
positional play to to go for in this
position so what do we do now 95 right
95 looks like the most logical move the
bishop
Quantic f2 probably queen take F 2 I
agree and perhaps if white can
consolidate the position make sure the
d4 pawn isn't too much of a target it
seems like it would be a long
strategical battle ahead maybe with some
advantage to white given that blacks
king is also somewhat exposed ideas like
Queen f7 could be coming along with 96
black does have to be careful here and
what if I go Queen f6 I feel like the
pawn on d2 can be really a huge weakness
so if I go Queen f6 try to try the Queen
and go into an endgame
yeah Queen f6 maybe not a this is not a
bad positional move because when you
when your King is perhaps a bit exposed
sometimes you want to aim free trades
just to make the King a bit a bit safer
and we should keep in mind that the more
pieces that could get traded off the
board the more amplified White's
weaknesses become especially the pawn on
d4 and perhaps a potential weakness on
b2 as well well which which color would
you figure Eric I'm probably to take me
back you would take black I would have
to take white then I think why does not
force to trade Queens and I really like
the combination of the two knights I
mean these are two beautiful outpost
squares if we continue this line perhaps
one move further we see a move like
Queen g3 avoiding the Queen trade and I
learned when I was very young that in
the middle game sometimes two Knights
can perform better than knight in Bishop
just because Knights can coordinate well
if you find the right squares for them I
won't disagree with that but I really
don't like the pawn on d4 I would not
like to play with it okay let's see how
the game is gonna unfold and maybe let's
move on to we should take a look at the
Benjamin Bach for Kobe in game when we
last left off the position was getting
very very interesting with that
explosive pawn see for break a lot of
places develop since
and they're only on move 23 it seems
like vara Cobian has a massive time
advantage over 20 minutes on the clock
Benjamin Bach under 2 minutes we could
see var staying perfect if he wins this
game he'll move on to four out of four
Weebly doesn't have too many troubles
and very direct way to play just crash
the queenside develop the rook and see
what what else is there it's true we
have to keep in mind that both Kings are
looking to be a bit unsafe in this
position I mean White's King on c1 black
has a lot of a lot of pressure happening
on the Queen side with the rook on b8
and the Queen on a4 but meanwhile blacks
King Gandhi 7 also not the safest piece
in the world given on being on the same
file as as a light rook so I think it
can get even more tactical and this
definitely favors the side with more
time which is what I really like about
White's position is the bishop on e4 and
Bishop on e3 because they aren't
covering the diagonal h1 to a8 and t1 to
87 so there is no Ruby that can go
actually to the a file yeah I would have
to agree that I mean White's bishops
look beautiful in this position when you
compare them to blacks bishops I mean
it's a somewhat open position and it
seems like bendin Benjamin Bach is doing
better with with the placement of his
minor pieces but it doesn't always tell
the whole story in the position so this
is certainly another game to keep an eye
on I do want to go back to the vistara
Bailey game because there have been some
developments I would expect Rinat you
mabye of to still be very low on time
but it is Wasif smooth and actually I
have to correct myself they just made
move 40 so some he Renaud can can
breathe a bit easier given that he he is
not below a minute he has 31 minutes on
the clock and the chief is taking some
time here I am wondering what vas if can
play here probably one of the options is
she takes h5 just to try to crash on the
Kings side and see what I can do there
and we should just take a moment to
count material I mean if if I can do
math properly White has an extra rook
for just a few pawns
and with with a still very menacing
attack on the kingside I I wouldn't be
surprised if or not resigns and in just
a few more rows yeah this is this is a
very difficult position for black there
are no choices no chances to really go
after the white king the king is perfect
yeah I don't see if I don't see many
options here for black and we are kind
of reaching the moment where players are
reaching move forty getting more time
I'm not sure if we have a graphic but we
should take a look at the the results so
far given the matchups and Group a
because there have been some some games
which have finished
we have draws between yara arabic and
alexander in jets and a draw between sam
Sevilla and Daniel Friedman but there
are still three results still pending
between Benjamin Bach for Kobe and visi
star Bayley renacchi mabye of and Peter
Piroska Jeffrey Zhang and let's look
maybe back to the Verico Beyond and
Benjamin ball ball game because he found
a really nice idea I like that
he played King d2 just trying to
transfer the King to a safer side on the
Kings side and then not worry about
anything any attack on the king this is
unexpected but it looks incredibly
logical I mean when your house is
burning burning down it's time to move
homes and it seems like the simple plan
of perhaps kingi to rook he1 King f1 I
really admire this idea from Edmund Bach
finding king d2 with with not too much
time on the clock and black can probably
do the same just King e8 King f8 and
everyone is saying safe everyone is
happy yeah we don't see this too often
where both Kings are just kind of taking
some sometimes it's a fine safer squares
but it seems like it seems logical for
both sides and this might turn from a
very tactical crazy battle to a more
positional battle especially going
forward if both Kings do find safety we
can see some imbalances in the pawn
structure and I might have to prefer
white in this position given the
superior bishops and given blacks
potential weaknesses both on on d6 and
c4 but I'm not sure if I would I would
take white in this position given his
time situation
yes those are time is always an issue in
a game and we have to think about it
but I feel that White's position is
really safe especially especially black
cannot take on before because it takes
before and white is gonna be the one
who's gonna be nominate dominating the a
file that's very true and it seems like
a critical moment I mean VAR we can see
his hands on his face taking this very
seriously he has 17 minutes to figure
out what to do in this position
I mean White's King still is on D - so
if black can maybe utilize the next two
moves to create some some issues for
white sometimes when you're especially
when your opponent's king is on an
awkward square looking to find safety
this is a the the key moment to try and
create an initiative in the position
there is a move that pops out here this
somewhat feisty pollen f5 and maybe
Larkin can create some King side attack
and actually what happened the game is
Bishop f6 so far I decided to go for a
safe move to improve the bishop at angle
C 3 I don't see any other move for white
just maybe kini - maybe idea is to play
Queen B 3 to try to try the Queen's and
have some attacks with the bottom b3 -
to promote that's true I actually I kind
of like this position I get Queen b3
because the bishop would support both c4
and b3 if we imagine some Lion King e2
Queen b3 the Queen's get traded white
would be left with a very weak pawn on
on c3 also on the half-open file and
this very it seems like an overextended
pawn on on b3 for black but it's well
supported by the bishop and it could
cause some headache for white going
forward in the game yeah white played
King e2 so what doesn't mind play skinny
- I think we'll go back to this game but
let's see the graphics for Group B what
happened today what are the results
that's right and we should keep in mind
we did have some very quick draws in
Group B
a few coach versus student matchups the
game between alejandro ramirez and JJ
Ali mirandy finished very quickly in a
credibly symmetrical exchange French for
and then taught to Vivaro Mian drawing
her former coach Josh credo and also a
quick game and we did see that game
sorry game at Cinco defeating Vladimir
Bellis this is not Vladimir balises
tournament unfortunately for him so we
have two games pending in in Group B
dinara saga Kesava against andrey zhuk
open and camille dragon still still
playing against robert august Arion so
maybe we should take a look at the the
dragon august re and game where I mean
things are heating up there's still a
black pawn on g3 they have ten more
moves to to get to move 40 and okay both
players are not in severe time trouble
but I mean nine minutes on the clock 12
minutes on the clock that's not a lot of
time to make 10 more moves I think we
need four is a nice idea to just capture
on i-4 and try the Queens I'm sorry how
how are we trading with means if I take
if let's say black is to move now I can
take on f4 and I'm forcing the trade of
the Queen's on f2 f2 okay yeah pawn take
f2 is is a threat and if we keep in mind
what we mentioned earlier a queen trade
could benefit black and in many cases
where where white has a maybe slightly
worth pawn structure this does seem like
a critical moment I mean there's a lot
of tension between the pawns we should
also keep in mind the d4 pawn is
attacked so white probably has to
respond to this one of the first moves
that comes to mind is it look like
rookie 4-2 to defend the pawn and attack
the Queen but I wouldn't be surprised if
things got traded relatively soon yes
and if Robert wins against camel Dragoon
he catches him with two with three and
half points I believe two and a half
points out of four so that's definitely
his goal that's right and it's very key
matchup for the tournament so this is
certainly a game to keep our eyes on
there has been a move played kamil
dragon getting up from the board
maybe maybe taking a coffee break that
the extra boost when you're when you're
getting in time pressure he played the
move Knight to f3 which also looks very
logical similar to rookie for white
taxa Queen defends upon now it's a
question for black do you do you trade
on f2 immediately or do you move your
queen somewhere that's a good question I
mean if I play something like Queen f4 I
have to be also careful about running
into 96 right 96 is always looming in
the in this position and I mean whenever
you're playing chess you want to look
for squares in your opponent's territory
that you control very well I mean white
having two too powerful pieces
controlling this e6 square so I don't
think that's a move that that black
would like to run into yes I can imagine
exchange on f2 Queen exchange and then
maybe a6 can get seven so the very very
simple G take f2 Queen take f2 then
you're saying trade Queens mm-hmm still
a bit unbalanced position I mean it
seems like white would have more
activity here despite maybe the
suboptimal pawn structure and we have to
keep in mind I mean whites whites
Knights are still pretty active in the
position white still has access to this
e6 square and not to mention this pawn
to c6 could also be a long-term weakness
but let's not forget the weakness on d4
that's right I mean when both sides have
weaknesses it creates for a more
interesting battle and sometimes the
position becomes how you how you best
defend your own weaknesses and how you
capitalize on your pawns weaknesses so
perhaps there would be chances for both
sides so let's see what Robert decides
to play here and maybe let's move on to
Daenerys game against Andres to copying
sure and this game I don't think we've
taken a look at too much throughout the
day we had a catalan in which black
played a stone wall variation it seems
like stuck open is a one perhaps trying
to play for a win given he is a higher
player here the current position
happened after Knight to e4 played at
first glance this is looking like a very
peculiar move given that White has one
to three attackers on e4 there's only
one defender so whenever we take with a
pawn from d5 again the d4 weakness as we
saw
the previous game that can be an issue
that's right so even if white attempts
to win a pawn it could severely backfire
if we imagine take take of course white
without should not take with Bishop
given this should take thee four would
actually be winning material for black
so I guess it's a question can might
take on e4 once with a minor piece and
then with the rook we can see play is
developing Knight a key for is played
pawn take e for now the question is can
like get away with rook taking four and
for the time being white is defending
the d4 pawn enough times but I'm curious
about this move Bishop g6 bishop GC just
do four zero Kuwait just make the rook
move and I mean black is not only gonna
maybe win the D pawn but he he would
then eventually when the exchange right
so what's gonna be do you think that's
just a lost position for a white or
white probably shouldn't take on e4 with
the rook this is this is a current
position after kontiki four looks like
whites white is thinking here it looks
like what can have an intermediate move
Bishop d6 to attend the rook on FA and
then to recapture on e4 it's a very nice
idea making use of what I was talking
about earlier where white is controlling
a key square in Black's territory very
well why not put the bishop on g6 it
obstruct the Queen along the D file this
is a very nice offensive but also
defensive move so probably Ruki eight
after Bishop d6 rook e8 but then can we
go ahead and just take the pawn would
rook yes
rook to e4 and I mean that the bishop is
just amazing on g6 just blocking any any
pressure from the Queen and is white
maybe playing for some advantage here
it's interesting how one wolf can make a
difference when we stop black from
attacking the d4 square we suddenly can
take control of the c6 weakness and
maybe utilize that that's right and even
though dinara is a lower seed I would
have to maybe prefer her position and
also the time situation we
should mention she has just over 14
minutes on the clock
stuck open just has over two minutes so
very nice time advantage for for dinara
going into the the final moves before
move 40 so let's move on maybe two
different game we have a result camel
dragon game against Robert a Kesari and
they agreed on a draw that's rising we
do have a 30 move no draw rule they
agreed to a draw on move 31 and what
seemed to be a very complex and fighting
position but comely still the leader of
the tournament so let's see ma'am you
will be able to get him to the studio to
talk about him what are his goals for
this tournament absolutely and I mean
maybe taking the draw was just a matter
of not taking too much risk just just
play it safe given that the position was
very complex both players were running
low on time and sometimes when you're
leading a tournament you you don't want
to go too crazy you want to you want to
stay disciplined you want to make make
good and well-informed decisions and
don't want to take too much risk so
maybe not a bad decision by a community
to take the draw so we have only last
last game in the tournament P Danny
dinara Sidhu cassava against Andres to
cotton so that's the only game to keep
an eye on so maybe let's move to the
tournament a what about Jeffrey's young
Peter Prohaska is it total draw now I
mean every time we look at this game
more material coming off the board makes
me sleepy sleepier and sleepier King f3
just played I'm not sure who is even
playing for a win here I mean I really
don't know do you think that why he
wants to go King g3 king h4 king g5 King
f6 walk around with the King try and
create some play I I mean it just seems
like there's not enough pawns on the
board to create any any active active
plans but one thing I know about Jeffery
he does not like to take draws in too
many positions I actually played him of
years ago at one of one of the
tournaments in st. Louis and I played
him in the last round where he was
leaving the tournament a draw would
guarantee guarantee him first place and
a very nice prize I offered him a draw
on maybe move ten and he turned it down
as black and he was playing for a win
the whole game I played with Jeffrey
also like about four years ago here in a
close tournament and we also it was very
long very long game we were the last in
the in the tournament hall but it was
very fighting and none of us wanted to
make a draw but you know in this
position I feel like he has nothing to
maybe Peter has nothing to lose he can
just improve his Bishop to d5 walk
around with the King and see if there
are any chances that's true we have to
keep in mind that a maybe Peter is
playing for two results but I'm sure
this game can go on for a lot longer in
the meantime we are going to take a
break and we will be back with a guest a
moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership there's
a weekend vacation
[Music]
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chess tour
st. Louis rapid and Blitzen Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis st. Louis
chess club celebrating its 10th
anniversary and these tournaments will
be a highlight you won't want to miss
for tickets and more information go to
st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a crucial situation in this game
Matheny must make a move but what will
it be all eyes are on the theme to make
a move a lot easier if you weren't doing
that right next to me it doesn't bother
me check the st. Louis Chess Club
celebrating ten years of promoting
teaching and playing the game of chess
visit the st. Louis chess club and help
celebrate our 10th anniversary
welcome back to the studio everyone I'm
international master Eric Rosen joined
by tournament leader Camille dragon
current congratulations so far on on
leading the tournament thank you yeah
everything sure why not
you had a relatively quick but fighting
draw today perhaps you can take us
through the game and then maybe talk
about the key moments yeah sure
so it started as what seemed to be a
relatively positional Queens gambit
declined it was this an opening that you
were expecting yeah
my opponent is playing only this
variation so mm-hmm
and at what point where you may be out
of your ear preparation or out of your
comfort zone honestly g6 was new kind of
new I know one game after g6 it was
Carson arena but after e3 Bishop a5
Carson played 22 Queen d2 the idea is to
play I think g4 and to develop somehow
but I did I didn't I didn't know how
because Iranian played after Queen d2 h5
forties I don't think it's good move
because now after Bishop different this
is like better reduction for me then in
the game because
h5 is yeah h5 seems weakening in the
sometimes you don't want to commit your
pawns too early as it is it is creating
weaknesses on the Kings side so with
Bishop d3 improvised then I knew that I
have two moves here Queen d2 or Bishop
d3 and I just didn't decide before the
game what should I play so during the
game I just was thinking like five
minutes and I chose should be free
because it's like mmm safer option I
think fair enough so did you feel like
you had any chance in the chances in
this game I mean we were looking at it
throughout the broadcast and we thought
okay we thought the opening was
relatively quiet but then later in the
middle game I mean it seemed like there
were many complications yeah it was I I
think I was little better somehow
somewhere but I'm not sure where exactly
because here I didn't know how so that I
knew that I should play before somewhere
but I didn't know where exactly sure if
or is maybe one of the only pawn breaks
in the position to consider Katarina and
I were playing this out before the
broadcast and I was suggesting perhaps
this unusual maneuver tonight a 2 2 c1 2
D 3 getting perhaps a more ideal night
in the center is this something that you
considered yeah but I considered it
before like before putting through on
the one I wanted and no earlier so 92 or
Nike 2 in this position yeah start 92
mm-hmm and what I wasn't sure about
rocks yet for instance nice c1 and c5
make this is exactly what Katherine and
I were playing out where it seems like
luck maybe take advantage of the
awkwardness of whites whites maybe slow
plan yeah no I cannot allow him to play
c4 so I have to take it 95
but maybe I'm fine here I can play in 94
for instance 94 and yeah I thought this
was maybe something which could happen
where you you go for some positional
play against this isolated deep on but
you are maybe a bit passive in this
position yeah I was like can I be free
in 94 oh I wasn't sure about that sure
yeah so let's go back to the game and
let's zoom forward were there any
moments where you thought maybe you had
any deviations together to get some
advantage yeah like instead of Bishop e5
I wanted to play before but I realized
that there is there is not not not for
me
I think after taking everything there
it's just trading everything I'm afraid
yeah like 94 94 I wanted to take by
night only for because I thought that it
would be good for me but after 95 I
realized that he will just play 27 25 or
27 Rocky 6 mm-hm
and I was like okay
even after Bishop Jeffrey and even if I
play somewhere 95 you can just take it
and after that f-16 katta7 sure I
doesn't seem to impress it for white
yeah I'm sure
so let's go forward towards the end of
the game I do want to ask how the game
ended because it seemed like there was
no repetition did you offer a draw did
he offer a draw
yeah I thought that I'm not better
I think it's equal position but I feel
felt even a little uncomfortable so I
offered a draw but probably it wasn't
like nothing special I see because after
GF here we have two Queen King have two
you can play something like 96 I think
mm-hmm and yeah I mean it seemed like
white spawns could be weak in the long
term and maybe slightly more cousin
pleasant for black yeah because my rock
is quite active so I can play always
something like Ruby 6 but I didn't want
to play fair enough yeah I mean why not
save some energy for the future rounds
no now you are leading the tournament
you have what three three out of four if
I'm not mistaken yes do you know who you
play tomorrow against Vlad yeah
ole against Vladimir who is is very much
struggling throughout this event do you
have any thoughts going into that game
honesty I'm little scared of this game
because he is like zero out of four but
he is very unpredictable player so you
can just start playing very strong and I
don't know when so I hope it's not
tomorrow I see it's it's certainly not
nothing to take for granted and I'm sure
you're still have to take it very
seriously I do want to ask - is this
your first time in st. Louis yeah and
what do you think about the tournament
so far the tournament conditions you
like it here yeah I'm very positively
surprised of the conditions of the
tournament it's like something new in us
for me because the tournament's new us
are much faster and this one who is
there is like couple rounds per
per day so I had some problems when I
arrived here to get used to it
fair enough yeah so I won't keep you any
longer I'll let you go get some rest let
you prepare for tomorrow best of luck in
the rest of your games
thank you for sure so moving back to the
games which are still going and
scrolling through here there are a lot
of games still over are still yeah there
are a lot of games over but there are
some games still happening the game that
still catches my eye is the battle
between vicita or Bailey and Renata
mabye of when we last left off I thought
the game was just gonna go maybe a few
more moves in black would resign but
Rinat appears to be fighting here even
though he's down the rook the position
still seems maybe not that simple to
actually break through for white the
current position Black has just played
Bishop EA to g6 and we do have to keep
in mind there are some targets for black
to attack the rook on b1 is now aligned
with the bishop and also this King on
each one it doesn't have the greatest
shelter in the world given given that
White has extended most of the pawns on
the kingside Wasif is thinking here he
has plenty of time and I'm sure he's
just looking for some perhaps
simplifying variations if he can force
any sort of Queen trade it'll just be a
Brook up up a rook in the endgame but
I'm sure he's also maybe looking for a
way to to capitalize on still this this
menacing attack with his rook aligned
with blacks King maybe he's considering
some move like pawn take h5 and I mean
it looks it looks very very scary for
black so we'll keep an eye on this game
and I am joined back with with Catarina
and i'm sylva welcome back Catarina
thank you any thoughts about the game so
far I would like to look at what's
happening in the Benjamin broken Farah
go beyond game that's right and this is
our key matchup of today we haven't
looked at this game she recently is it's
interesting how the Queen was speaking
about playing with the Queen Queen b3
and suddenly the queen is on g5 yeah so
so far Akopian did not use your idea of
perhaps infiltrating White's territory
and the position has changed drastically
since from from earlier whites Kings
have found safety both on the Kings side
and now it seems to be a positional
struggle at first glance I I do like
White's position given the rook is
beautiful beautifully placed on d4 and
it's very hard for almost impossible for
black to remove this piece meanwhile
these pawns on c4 and d5 are fixed on
light squares and I know just a few days
ago we had so many games with bishops of
the same color this position no
different where I mean it seems like
white has some long-term weaknesses to
attack in the center yes and the bishop
on e6 I mean that's almost like a pawn
it doesn't do anything more than just
defends the pawn on d5 and maybe defends
the square on i-5 that's true when I
teach my younger students and there's a
bishop kind of sandwiched between its
own two pawns I like to call this a
pointless Bishop where yeah it's not not
that effective in this position this is
why we we want pawns on the opposite
color of the bishop in such situations
so why is the pawn kind of advantage on
the Queen side with the a and B pawn
ready to go for some promotion and it's
a long-term advantage for white that's
very true yeah this uh this two-on-one
majority has to give some light house to
give White's in long long term chances
going forward into the endgame there
have been a couple moves played Bara
played rook to e8 and Benjamin Bach
played Queen c1 and I do have to point
out it appears that this game has not
reached move 40 yet both players in
severe time time trouble being less than
a minute and they still have eight moves
to go and a queen c1 I like this move
you don't have enough time there is
nothing to think about
so let's just try the Queen's let's go
to a better and game let's have this
slight long-term advantage I think
that's a wise decision for sure I mean
especially when you have the the better
column structure you you want to go for
trades because when you trade off pieces
the weaknesses amplify in this case the
more trades like that happened in the
position the the more worries black
probably has with with
the center pons so I think bara very
wisely avoided the Queen trade he played
the move Queen f6 maybe trying to keep
some attacking potential of giving
White's King is placed on f2 and now
Benjamin Bach is thinking with less than
30 seconds left and we have some
developments in the dinara Andres game
so what if we look there we thought
Bishop d6 is a great move maybe securing
white some advantage but and Andre I
thought about some interesting moves
that's right and we should keep in mind
this is a final game happening in Group
B when we last left it seemed like black
was doing very well but you know this
Bishop on g6 this idea that we mentioned
earlier maybe my mistake white was doing
very well and and white seems to be very
happy here
but dinara her time is dwindling looks
like she just has under six minutes left
and Andres to cope in under a minute
with five moves to go what if we go back
so it'll be show d6 move and see what
happened there
yeah because Dre did not play what we
said would be sorted if you played the
counter-attack you move Bishop g5 I mean
when you're being attacked
of course defense is a obvious option
but Bishop g5 perhaps a nice
counter-attack Queen c2 played and then
be for another counter-attack leaving
the rook on f8 still attacked for the
time being
rook b3 played and then perhaps the
exchange sacrificed Bishop f6 targeting
the d4 pawn and maybe making the
argument that the bishop on g6 is more
valuable than the rook on F aids and if
the bishop on decks d6 disappears and
Bishop take FA then Queen take f8
happens then the c5 phone will also be a
weakness it's true we should point out
that would have the intermediate move
Bishop take t4 check force the King to
move and then Queen take f8 and yeah
maybe there's some compensation for
black in this position the two bishops
can combine very well together
especially in open positions like this I
do want to go forward to the current
position though there are a lot of
developments happening rook take e for
is played bishop g6 with the skewer
looks like maybe both sides are losing a
rook for a bishop so this might just be
a fair trade but Queen c4 check happened
King
shades and many more moves have been
played rookie 1 okay so I think this is
a current position Bishop of 7bh8 rookie
1 bishop f7 d5 Wow just lunging forward
in the center d5 is supported by the
bishop on g2 Queen and c4 which brings
us to the current position rookie Yates
finally moves the rock away doesn't give
it up that's right and I I mean I'm not
sure what's going on here that that is
interesting to point out the rook on f8
was attacked by the bishop for for so
many moves I think it was about 6 or 7
moves there any thoughts about this
position who stands better or is it just
too crazy to tell well dinner is 2
minutes and 30 seconds whereas Andre
less than a minute so that's clearly an
advantage plus I think after what what
about the rubies BAE 3 makes a lot of
sense I mean the rook seems been doing
nothing on unbe 3 currently and the
e-file is one of the only open files so
why Knox we don't need to be also losing
the pawn b2 so but maybe that's gonna be
a sacrifice let's write sometimes
physicians like this piece activity is a
lot more important than pawns
especially if things start getting
tactical and of course it's much easier
to play in time trouble when you have
initiative and sometimes you don't want
to be too materialistic my guess is Ruby
e3 that's what's gonna happen ARA is is
pondering the position both players
silhouetted there with with being right
next to the window we will keep an eye
on the scheme they have two more moves
to make until move 40 any other games to
to go to we don't have too many games
left do you want to go Peters Prohaska
and Geoffrey drunk you keep directing to
that game let's go through busted or
wily against when I do my body's an
exciting game so if I see if is still
thinking here I mean he has enough time
to maybe sort through all the
complications but sometimes as we saw
yesterday in the ha Alejandro games
sometimes the hardest thing to do in
chess is to convert an advantage
or approval winning position and maybe
or not is trying to use some some last
resources to to put the pressure on the
Seif and it's interesting let's save a
thief play something like pawn takes h5
maybe Renaud can just play Bishop f5 and
the point is actually blocking the rook
on h2 to attack the king and the king
can be in safety it's actually a really
nice idea Bishop f5 basically closes
down a lot of open lines on the Kings
side and the pawn and h5 actually acts
as a shield for the BOK King given the
rook is just kind of staring at its own
pond I do like this idea they should buy
five plus there are some tricks like 9f2
after pond xh5 maybe 9 f2 and taking the
rock on b1
mmm additionally we always have to keep
in mind the tactics in the position and
I have two very possible so you're
saying that if pawn to h5 Knight f2
let's say rook take f2 though I don't
know if this would work
given that white has queen a sudden in
the very end and it takes if take take
White's up at Bishop but maybe it's
playable King G I mean I don't want to
trade
no this trouble loss no never mind I do
have to open I mean that's maybe the
position is just lost it's very hard to
with so many lions I mean that if the
position ever simplifies Wasif is the
one up material so right I think if we
see this position happen after a GT h5
we're probably likely to see Bishop f5
and then it's more of a question like
how how does white break through and
sometimes these situations that the the
better side has to actually come up with
ideas and all black has to do is react
to what white is doing so that's why the
thief will probably continue to take a
lot of time here and he appears to be
incredibly focused hovering over the
board or not Juma buy of maybe coming
back to the board sipping some tea or
coffee I wouldn't be surprised if a
thief takes some more time here to
figure things out we have yes all the
time he needs
so I don't think he's worried about this
game so let's move on somewhere else you
don't want to see Peter prohaszka's game
so what about the VAR and Benjamin block
you have the key matchup of today yeah
let's get to that game because when we
last left both sides were in time
trouble they are still both in severe
time trouble both player is having less
than one minute on the clock but they
have one more move to make time control
we should stay on this game at least
until they reach move 40 novartis 17
minutes to do so 17 seconds yeah not too
much time and var is somewhat notorious
for getting long time seems like he very
enthusiastically just played his last
move rook to e8 still very very focused
on the position and that was actually
the 39th move so one more move for each
player to reach move 40 time is ticking
down for Benjamin Bock less than 20
seconds left it's a play something like
ruk a 3-2 try to trade it I broke a 3
maybe not a bad decision given you you
want to go for simplifications he played
the move looks like Bishop c2 if I can
see correctly and oh it's a nice stretch
because after rook takes c3 there is
Bishop 8 7 Wow
so it's white winning material here bar
might be in trouble he doesn't have much
time less than 20 seconds on the clock
or is there to sacrifice that vari is
gonna play Bishop a5 I mean what else to
do he might be as he forced to sacrifice
he is less than 10 seconds may does move
rook takes c3 which does reach move 40
but it allows the simple tactic Bishop
h7 check and I believe we can expect
this position after King take h7 Queen
takes c3 is white just off a clean
exchange Gary I mean this I thought
there are more chances when the ponies
and ponies on b3 here I feel like white
is safe yeah I mean
that these these two pawns still fixed
on light squares the bishop still being
pointless on e6 we should mention and
black does have a pawn for the exchange
but this past beep on this could this
could lead white to winning a game so
let's go back to Daenerys game because
she did play Ruby III and sacrificed the
pawn on b2 so what is happening there
they reached a move for T so they have
extra 30 minutes to think about for the
remainder of the game
yeah this is another crazy position and
they did reach time control so both
players having some time to maybe calm
down get some coffee figure out what's
going on this this could be a very long
fight from here let's just go back and
see how they came to this position
because looks like dinara did play your
recommendation rook be3 going for
e-filing I'm thinking about a position
now though I'm what if we play maybe
just rube d1 I think just keeping the
pressure on d5 can be also an
interesting option oh you're saying
instead of rupees yes
rook t1 and now my idea is just to move
the Queen away and then then if you take
on d5 I'm happy to recapture with light
square bishop that's right we should
mention this the set up with a bishop on
d6 and pawn on c5 it's so stable and
maybe white should sure they've left the
tension in the position but I do admire
a p3 I mean why it's not an interesting
idea to go for an attack and try
something I do like doing this move
because the rook on year was probably
blacks best rook after it gets traded
black is left with the rook on a8 which
is doing nothing in the current position
white did lose upon and b2 but white got
some activity rookie 7 bishop g8 played
the setup looks a bit iffy for black
given the King on the h8 bishop on g8
and it seems like white just has
complete dominance in the center that's
true and now
probably has to recap 25 otherwise white
will take on c6 and that one is gonna be
dangerous
well whites threat is probably to move
the Queen first maybe to square like
origin we need people's already played
Oh Queen d3 was played okay so white
does have the threat of taking on c6 and
now it's it's Andres move what to
consider here for black there's there's
still the tension does black have to
take on d5 Bishop f6 can be alternative
to go on a tag to rook
yeah Bishop f6 perhaps definitely a
candidate move concedes Inara not at the
board
Andre thinking sometimes when you reach
move 40 you just want to stand up
stretch your legs get something to eat
because it's still probably going to be
a long fight ahead yes so what if we go
back to vas Eve's game we have some new
moves there so you have a C finally play
the move after a very long think 21
minutes he spent on move Bishop h4 Wow
which we were not considering I think we
were looking at the most natural G take
Age 5 Bishop h4 maybe he wants to
prevent all the knight moves to g3 or or
f2 and be always ready to recapture with
Bishop that's true we should keep in
mind when when the bishop is is three
files away from a knight it does a good
job of controlling a lot of squares that
the knight wants to move to as we can
see just a geometry in this position the
knight really can't move towards the
Kings side without being captured by the
bishop we should mention though the rook
on b1 still undefended still aligned if
black really wants to maybe move like 93
is still possible but if we look how the
position could unfold I don't think it
would end too well for black and the
sign after Bishop take me one rook take
h5 s would just be winning for whites
and his idea can be also going with the
bishop to e1 and e2 and forcing the
exchange of Bishop for a knight
because every change benefits white who
is look up let's not forget that that's
true
that's actually a very creative maneuver
which which didn't come to my mind
immediately where yeah you want you want
the Queen Bishop battery but you want
the Queen to be leading the battery for
those who don't know a battery in chess
is when two pieces are aligns that move
in the same direction in this case the
Queen and Bishop moving along the
diagonal but if we imagine the bishop
reaches oops if we go back to the
current position if the bishop were to
reach this D to square it the Queen
would be leading the battery of battery
with the very menacing threat Queen h6
check and if I'm not mistaken I just
want to go back earlier this game
because I think the thief used a very
similar idea in the middle game looking
here on move 16 just a quick throw back
to the middle game when he played Bishop
d1 it was pretty much the same idea
where he wanted to play the very
sensible Queen d3 and Bishop c2 so I
think that's what we can feel from the
grandmasters game how they really know
how what their peers are doing and maybe
when they are not placed in the best way
and they know how to improve them it's
very true it's not just about optimizing
the pieces but it's about making the
pieces work together to put maximum
pressure on the opponent's h4 now Rina
Juma by a pest has to think what to do
next
he's only half point out of three games
so psychologically for him this game is
also very difficult he doesn't want to
have another loss it's not easy I mean
all the momentum going into the Chiefs
direction not just given the opening
from this game great opening preparation
by the sieve but the Turman situation is
Seif having three out of three Renacci
mabye of struggling to score points as
tournaments the month the momentum can
continue in this favor so let's look at
Peter Prohaska again Jeffrey Jones let's
see what's happening in that and game
who is playing for a win or why are they
you know why are they now deciding on a
draw who is playing for a win here I
mean it looks like maybe why it is
slight
for choice given this slightly more
beautiful bishop on d5 but Jeffrey has a
time advantage so you never know in
situations like this if maybe Jeffrey's
the one playing on trying to put Peter
in time pressure to provoke some blunder
later on it's interesting that white
played 93 allowing the Black Knight to
jump to c4 so why is it saying I don't
care if you jump to c4 probably I take
you with the bishop and I will be fine
yeah a line like this Knight c4 Bishop
takes c4 pawn takes e4 Knight c5 yeah
nice active square for the knight and
then maybe White has some some chances
in this position given all the Box pawns
would be isolated and the night can't be
challenged by the bishop
so if Jeffrey does not decide to go to C
Ford and the knight can go the white
knight can go to c5 and maybe try to
annoyed like there ya 95 coming but I
mean even if Y it finds perfect square
is for both denied and the bishop is
white really making that much progress
to cause issues for black yes I don't
know I I do think it's equal but you
never know what's gonna happen in these
games and how grandmasters
can improve their pieces so I have an
interesting question for you let's say
magnus carlsen is playing whites and
you're playing black how confident are
you that you could draw this position
wow that's a that's a tough question I
think play magnus carlsen you can be
never confident about anything I
remember he won a game rogue and game I
think three on three pawns I mean that's
a dead draw
actually no what can you're referring to
I think that was Carlsen pony Mario's
that was a great great instructive
position showing that sometimes even
very draw positions can can be maybe
still having some life to them if if
you're Magnus Carlsen yes exactly so
let's let's see what is happening in
Andres debulking did they make any moves
tera dinara against Andre yeah let's
take a look
Queen d3 was played so getting out of
the pen
from the bishop on g8 but not too many
developments
maybe we can speculate what black is
going to do here I mean we were both
admiring lights beautiful set up from
earlier but we should keep in mind the
the one perhaps good thing that black
can can play for in this position there
is a queen side magic majority with the
a5 on b4 pawn against the the a to pawn
so maybe black and perhaps dream of
pushing the pawns at some point but
doesn't seem to be an immediate plan for
black so Bishop f6 looks like a very
natural move at Bishop f6 get the bishop
to safety so what do you play afterwards
I would probably move the rook but the
question is where to move it to I mean
usually especially in these endgame
situations you want to keep your rook on
those active square as possible I'm
wondering if I could play the very
adventurous rook c7 and having the rook
deep in blacks territory and that looks
like a great move I'm just thinking
maybe are you giving up the e-file you
filed that can be my queen a queen e8
just trying to see I mean I let's say I
give up the pawn on c6 and try for some
counter-attack
so Queen e1 check yeah we do have to
keep in mind maybe White's King can be a
bit unsafe in these potential lines
Bishop to f1
though if White's not getting needed and
not losing material I mean these
especially this pawn in c6 could uh
could be making the game decisive for
whites yeah so what's happy eight here
so rook Yates trying to play this out
actually this looks a little bit scary
for whites given ax pieces seem to be
coordinating very well and I'm not sure
if Y can make enough progress before the
King site falls apart but the good part
for both players is that they have 30
minutes they have a lot of time to
calculate and really see what is what is
the best variation for them that's right
and I think dinara is the one dictating
the game I mean she doesn't have to be
so adventurous with rook c7 if she wants
to keep control over the C file or over
the e-file a move like rookie 2 or
rookie 1 very playable and just try and
play restrictive not let black get any
any unnecessary counter play so we have
a VAR nothing nobody is moving in these
games they are all thinking they are
happy to have 30 minutes reaching the
move 40 and that's what happens after
time control I mean a lot of the players
will maybe hunker down cool down from
the heated time pressure situation we
should keep in mind that if you're
watching the broadcast you can follow
all the games on us chess chance calm
and and check out the games for yourself
there there have been a good number of
exciting games today absolutely they are
very instructive how to play with PCs
and some crazy tactics and we should
take a look at just the results so far
for this round if we take a look at
Group A there have been a good number of
games that have finished if we if we go
through I'm just scrolling down here we
had a few draws so far euros Arabic
drawing Alexander in jets and in the
game that we didn't really take a look
at so let's take a look we still don't
have anything more interesting to look
at let's see how they made a draw yeah
we can go through this game quickly
seemed like one of these classic and
classic ready English positions both
sides kind of doing their own
I actually don't have too much
experience and these sort of setups from
either side have you played an opening
like this I do play this for black so
it's very solid we have some ideas some
flexible options with ecigs d5 or
sometimes II five f5 it this looks like
a very peaceful position yeah I think
both players maybe not having the best
result in the tournament and sometimes
when you're you're not having the best
result you just want to stop the
bleeding and and have at least a solid
game without too many mistakes it seems
like both players were playing like that
today we're okay not taking too much
risk the position stayed relatively
symmetrical things got traded I'm
looking here it doesn't seem like either
side is playing for much advantage and
do you have to point out they did agree
to a draw on move 31 so we have the
graphic so let's look at the like
standings for Group A yeah we have ok
still some games pending the key games
being version of Cobian and of course
the game with Wasif Tara Bailey against
for nacho mabye of if if a thief or a
Cobian wins they stay perfect and
they're they're getting off to just a
perfect start and we have a big game
tomorrow in Group A so let's see what is
the pairings for tomorrow so we have
Daniel Freedman against Benjamin bak
Alexander in Jets against Sam 7 jeffrey
zhang against euros arabic Renacci mabye
of versus peter carrasco and vara Cobian
against a thief dar bailey we had a tool
either as our three out of three right
now playing tomorrow that's going to be
a very exciting game that's right I mean
that's that's a huge matchup of a thief
having having a perfect score if he can
convert his advantage against a Cobian
and I mean a Cobian always playing for
for blood playing with fire and we'll
see if fr can keep his top hundred spot
in the light rating of this yes and vari
is gonna have white so it's gonna be
very interesting so let's see it alight
what is what are the life standing
Ruby that's right we have Camille dragon
who I interviewed not too long ago still
leading the pack three out of four not a
bad score and several players close
behind
JJ Allie Morandi drawing his his st.
Louis University chest coach Alejandra
Ramirez today both standing at two and a
half out of four and also Sergey Mont
Saint go with two and half out of four
and don't want to mention this but I
kind of have to flatten your Bell is
still struggling with the vent what do
you do when you have zero before how do
you how do you fight back in such a long
event I think that the goal is to like
cuddle losses to just one draw let's
just have a draw for tomorrow and then
you know you can refresh yourself and go
for a win I really hope he's gonna make
a draw or something tomorrow otherwise
that's gonna be so sad to have five
zeros that's very true so so let's look
what out of pairings for tomorrow yeah
in Group B we have we have many exciting
matchups Josh Reed elegance dinara Sidhu
a cassava Robert August Arion against
Tata of Abraham Ian Vladimir ballast
against Camille dragon which i think is
going to be the key matchup the
tournament leader against against last
place
camille saying that he's a little
nervous for that game because when
you're playing someone who's not having
the best performance they're probably
very loose are willing to take risks and
you still have to stay focused and not
take anything for granted in this game
we also have JJ Ally mirandy against
Sergei mots anko and andrey zhuk open
against Alejandro Ramirez many exciting
games today
so do we want to take a look at anything
happening today anything more exciting I
mean it seems like the players are just
using their their time for the fullest
we do have maybe one update in the
dinara game where andrey zhuk open has
captured pawn on d5 looks like we
finally have a result in the jeffrey
zhang peter Prochaska game that game was
almost putting me to sleep the entire
broadcast but they have finally agreed
to a draw we can see the Kings and the
center of the board there Mike emerge is
collecting the score sheets so we also
see Daenerys ah do cassava seems to be
very focused against the higher rated
andrey zhuk open in the current position
both sides having a lot of time 26
minutes for dinara 17 minutes
or just under 18 minutes for for Andre
so still some similar level to go yeah
so our predictions for the results of
this game so Benjamin ba gua rakubian
Baraka Brian is gonna struggle yeah I
mean it seems like white is the one
certainly playing for a win but at least
the Bishop on f5 not so pointless
anymore perhaps going for this this
juicy square on d3 maybe somewhat
reminiscent of the the junior game yes
so what about passive still putting some
pressure on Renaud yeah or if we're not
putting some pressure on to see if I
mean to see if is clearly the one
playing for a win and he has still a lot
of time to perhaps sort through the
complications I have to put my money on
the C's absolutely I agree so let's go
as there any other games we have in
tournament B dinara pseudo cassava
against Andres took off in and it
appears they are trading on d5 looks
very likely that these LightSquared
bishop s-- will get traded and then it's
so kind of a pawn race between blacks
Queen side pawn majority and whites past
C pawn I would have to favor in favor
white in this position given the C pawn
is not only well defended but very far
advanced there's the importance the
white is gonna be faster in going C 67
and then the back rank it's gonna be
very dangerous for black that's true the
King on the h8 looks safe for the time
being but it is cornered and I mean at
least one of the black's pieces will
always have to keep in mind a frank so
if we imagine Bishop take to e5 Queen
taking five
seems like dinars playing for the win I
agree well let's see how the game is
gonna finish
and we have one update pawn a4 was
played we can see andrey zhuk open
leaving the board their positions like
this you do have to play quickly time is
very important especially when there's a
potential pawn race andrey wasting no
time playing this move a4 and actually
the idea is very interesting
he might be threatening some move like
b3 if we just play a waiting move for
white let's say say maybe not the best
move but let's say h3 we can see the
threat for black a3 pawn take beef or v3
pawn take b 3 and a 3 and this is not
what white would want to have happen i
think if i a 4 is a very interesting
move especially you can see Andre again
he doesn't care about the rook on a 8
he's like take the rook for a bishop the
bishop is more valuable then my bishop
on g8 is gonna be amazing supporting the
pawns for for promotion that's actually
really interesting I have to admit I did
not realize that rook is hanging but if
white takes it it might be drinking the
poison we're after Queen take a 8
whenever you you take one of your
opponent's bishops and you still have
that Bishop of the same color you're the
one who can dominate the that those
color squares in this case if the
LightSquared bishop for black ever comes
to life there could be some weaknesses
around the Kings side that white would
have to worry about maybe black is the
one who is now pushing for a win yeah
seems like a very short battle and I
wouldn't be surprised that both players
get into time trouble again and given
that this could be another very long
fight
very interesting games I really enjoy
seeing these fighting fighting games
fighting spirit
so anything any other games to take a
look at I mean both players or pretty
much all the players have enough time to
think I think we'll let the viewers
watch the games on their own and we'll
we'll wrap it up very soon if you want
to take a look at at the games you can
of course go to us chess champs calm and
see all the games being broadcast live
on chess 24 the games are starting at
1:00 p.m. tomorrow central time and and
will start the broadcast at 3:30 Central
Time
and before we completely sign off we
want to congratulate Julian June for
winning the 2018 women world
championship that's right a very
impressive win for her and historic
finished the the women's championship
absolutely I think he's the first title
for her and she's gonna enjoy well we'll
have a lot more exciting chests tomorrow
stay tuned and and see you tomorrow take
care bye
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you